to a time in miami i got to tell you
you're not feeling it
not feeling it you know whoa
no i didn't think people say that
i didn't say that why not
the timing just makes no sense well i
don't know because
ryan fitzpatrick is playing well they're
three and three they're coming off a 24
nothing shutout to the jets which i know
doesn't mean much so how about the week
before
where they destroyed the 49ers
i mean ryan fitzpatrick has been playing
well i get that he was always a
placeholder i get that
uh you know that you already know how
the movie's probably going to end with
his carriage turning into a pumpkin at
some point
but tuatanga valloa hasn't so much has
been tackled
since his injury at alabama
had five snaps and two passes
and you're putting him in against aaron
donald
and the rams after the bye week like i
know he's the future but this just feels
rushed to me
you know i might
it means it can mean a couple of things
one i like it because i i liked um
i liked uh tua
in college and i know chris sims we
talked with him he said that was not his
number one guy his number one guy was
justin herbert right
yeah so he really wasn't feeling too
well like that
but
he said oh you know he got a great
supporting cast around and all he had to
do was sit back and throw to these nfl
receivers protected by nfl offensive
line but there's a reason you took the
guy number five overall so
maybe the plan all along was make sure
he's healthy make sure we got an obvious
spot to put him in which is the bye week
yeah the bye week is always the logical
spot it's gonna be his job or oh
you ready for the other one
or
it's above
brian flores that's where i was going
that's where i was going that's exactly
what i was like i said put them in
that's what it feels like this does not
feel like a football decision because
the football decision is to let him
continue to sit and learn and to put the
guy out there who gives you the best
chance of winning now michael you and i
both know something if you have two
players
and they're on the same level
you played a younger guy
especially at quarterback you played a
younger guy okay yes but in this
instance
i have a hard time believing
that tuatanga valoa
gives the dolphins a better chance to
win more so now than he did a week ago
or a week before that or a week before
that like listen listen i'm not trying
to say that ryan fitzpatrick you know
should be the guy no matter what but
he's played well enough to keep the job
but then again maybe they looked at him
they're treating ryan patrick like he's
some like he's like he's a black interim
coach like his name is raheem morris no
matter what you do this ain't yours you
gotta win a level you can do to keep
this job yeah there's nothing you can do
to keep this job because it almost felt
like this was always the plan unless and
this is why you took the words right out
of my mouth
there was that great picture from the
weekend of tua sitting on the field
taking in the moment which was great
first time on the field uh since he
heard his hip you know for alabama right
there were the chance to uh to uh you
know the whole crowd is going crazy yeah
when he comes in even ryan's a great
picture guys
it's a great great picture
you mentioned justin herbert balling out
for the chargers joe burrow looks good
oh and don't forget the miami heat just
came off a great run
a great run in the nba bubble but you
and i both know that's a dolphins town
on south beach dolphins first and
they've been looking for damn for the
next dan marino for a long time this
feels like with all due respect to brian
flores and the football people stephen
ross says i got to get my guy in there i
gotta get my guy in there we need some
juice you know like dude you're three
and three
this patrick is playing very very well
the team is responding to fits right
through the wheels fall off don't push
don't put somebody else in the driver's
seat
in a winnable
for the fight when's the last time we
said this in a winnable amc east we just
talked about it yesterday the patriots
are two and three
and i'm not sure what i'm going to do
with my bad year money yet but i may
predict that they're going to go to two
and four after they play the 49ers in
jimmy garoppolo on sunday but i digress
so the patriots are two and three
buffalo's lost two straight you're one
game behind them
i know you played them already but it's
been it was a very competitive a very
competitive game
against the buffalo bills
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports